[Musik]
das podcast ist bei lm unique ja meine
damen und herren wir weiter mit benjamin
und zwar mit einer
geschichtsphilosophischen thesen
sie erinnern sich letzte woche ging es
um die frage gibt es fortschritt oder
weißes fortschrittsglaube und wie sollte
sich jetzt damals aktuell ende der 30er
jahre 1940 fortschrittlich darf man
nicht sagen aber ein linker denker mit
der geschichte auseinandersetzen wenn
ihr mit gegner ist ein allgemeiner
fortschrittsglaube der sich darauf
verlässt dass alles besser wird und
insofern nichts dazu tun muss oder oder
das nur passiv beobachten was im glauben
dass die geschichte auf der seite der
guten wäre so das ist eine kritik der
sozialdemokratie weiler dann sagte
dieser
[Musik]
diese zuversicht dass die geschichte
einen voran trägt und alles besser wird
ist eigentlich schuld daran
für die entkräften
und der revolutionären geist bei den
sozialdemokraten
wie gesagt also der hintergrund ist der
hitler stalin pakt und damit ein
allgemeiner zusammenbruch des
politischen fortschritt wir haben dann
auch zuletzt und angeschaut was ist dann
emotional oder oder oder was für ein
ansatz hat dann der historiker überhaupt
also wenn kein fortschritt
was ist was ist der inhalt der
geschichte und wie sollte der historiker
damit umgehen und das schlagwort rache
kam dann hoch der gedanke war oder
benjamin sack mit mit großer betonen
darf nach in die zukunft
schauen und und darüber rätseln wie die
zukunft werden könnte oder noch noch
zugespitzt
der versuchte die zukunft besser zu
machen ist letztendlich beitel was der
erlösung ist ja auch quasi religiöse
angst hier was der lösungs willige tun
sollte ist vor allem die
ungerechtigkeiten der vergangenheit
reichen also nicht den den eitlen
versuch unternehmen irgendeine eine
strahlende zukunft auszubauen sondern
bitter im bitte am hass er sagt auch
hass oder auch im opfer willen die
geknechteten vorfahren zu rechnen
also egal wo das hingeht wenn man sich
das bild vom engel der geschichte das
bild von von klee wo der engel mit dem
rücken zur zukunft sich bewegt also geht
es bewegt sich zwar mit der zeit aber
mit dem rücken zur zukunft gewarnt
das heißt ohne sich gedanken zu machen
was wird er stattdessen das ruinöse dass
die katastrophen der vergangenheit
irgendwie aufzuarbeiten oder mit mit
ihnen in irgendeiner form klar zu kommen
das ist dann das bild und benjamin sagt
in diesem zusammenhang gibt es zwei
varianten von geschichte es gibt den
historismus und es gibt den
die emanzipierte geschichte also wenn
man situation ist nicht so ein begriff
wie ich darf vielleicht schon eher
erlöste geschichte der historismus
arbeitet mit der addition und die sein
gegner arbeitet mit der konstruktion gut
und die frage für uns jetzt ist was
versteht er unter diesen begriffen und
was ist auch der hintergrund zu diesem
ansatz also nochmal alles klar ist dass
benjamin ablehnt ist das bestehende er
sagt auch dass kontinuierliche der
gedanke dass das dass die geschichte ein
kontinent bildet und letztlich ändert
sich nicht viel
oder wenn es sich verändert dann halt
immer auch derselben schiene
es ist vielleicht eine progression in
irgendeiner form aber es ist immer im
gleichen rahmen oder das ihn ebenfalls
dieses geschichte oder oder diese
inhalte von denen 30 benjamin absetzen
und um sie wahr machen und da wird also
beschreibt ja oder charakterisiert er
die die die inhalte die geschichtlichen
inhalte in diversen markigen sprüchen
beispielsweise wir sehen wir sicherlich
schon
in anderen zusammenhängen vorgekommen
ist die aussage dass etwas niemand
niemals ein dokument der kultur ist ohne
zugleich ein solches der barbarei zu
sein
das ist im abschnitt 87 ist es niemals
ein dokument der kultur ohne zugleich
ein solches der barbarei zu sein und wir
selbst nicht weiß und dabei so ist so
ist es auch der prozess der
überlieferung nicht in der es von dem
einen an den anderen gefallen ist
ok also die kultur die hochgepriesene
bürgerliche kultur rowland im
kulturtempel zum beispiel museen wohl
vielleicht auch universitäten weiß man
nicht aber jedenfalls das was als kultur
betrachtet wird ist ein dokument der
barbarei und der dienst an dieser kultur
ist ebenfalls nicht frei von barbarei ok
ich mal das ist eine ziemlich heftige
ablehnung
was er sich darunter vorstellt ist nicht
ohne weiteres deutlich meine benjamin
hat sich selbst mit dokumenten der
kultur eingehend auseinandergesetzt
beispielsweise in dem trauerspiel buch
oder in seinem aufsatz über goethes
wahlverwandtschaften
das sind ja auch kultur werke er sagt
aber auch gleichzeitig
die aufgabe des historikers ist die
geschichte gegen den strich zu bürsten
und der aus als über beispielsweise über
goethes wahlverwandtschaften ist schon
eine dekonstruktion ist im versuch
goethes aberglauben unter anderem
erkennbar zu machen ich meine es ist ich
weiß nicht ob das gelesen haben dass es
vielleicht nur für spezialisten aber es
ist es ist ein sehr schöner auftrags und
sehr auf sehr erhellend und lädt auch
dazu ein den romanen noch zu lesen wenn
es jetzt eigentlich kennen
aber wie gesagt ja benjamin würde
wahrscheinlich dann sagen dass die auch
an anderen stellen sagt was der
historiker in diesem zusammenhang macht
ist die quellen unbrauchbar machen für
den gegner
und es ist ein bürsten gegen den strich
in dem sinne dass das goethe dann am
ende da stehen wie gesagt alles unter
anderem falls ein abergläubischer mensch
und das ist natürlich nicht nicht
unbedingt das was man normalerweise
in der überlieferung muss nicht
vorstellen bei goethe
also das ist sicher vielleicht eine
möglichkeit ist es nicht so dass
benjamin sich grundsätzlich von allen
absetzt in der kultur vielleicht
irgendwas man das so sehen also dass die
überlieferung das nicht so handhaben
darauf die kultur nicht so handhaben
darf als wir es immer noch beute im
triumphzug der herrschen also wenn man
das irgendwie andere gegen den strich
bürstet wie benjamin dass in seinem fall
verwandschaften auch sonst versucht dann
ist das hier ja eine rettung also damit
wird wie gesagt
goethe selbst nicht herabgestuft
meine ist weiterhin auch nach lektüre
des dass er vielleicht noch
interessanter ist er vorher war es kein
held der geistesgeschichte wie beim golf
oder dem georg kreis dieser gedanke dass
die dichter also das ist sicherlich eine
perspektive elemente der georgen kreis
den er mehrfach explizit ablehnt hatte
ja diesen gedanken georges der dichter
stefan georg mehr
ein führer buch stell mich ein führer im
bereich der kultur und gunther friedrich
gundolf der mann ist in dem namen der
über goethe und shakespeare geschrieben
hat bei dem wäre das auch eine
darstellung von von diesen im
letztendlich unkritisch abgebildeten
kultur helfen okay das darf es jetzt
ebenfalls nicht so an das ist ein aspekt
gut aber ein hintergrund dazu irgendeine
1 1 aus richtung den benjamin jetzt
weniger oder gar nicht weit aber
vielleicht auch im hintergrund im kinder
im hintergedanken hat ist natürlich die
architektur der kultur
es ist schon so dass es diese
heldenhaften inhalte entsprechend auch
baut verbaut werden
das eine ich habe schon erwähnte museen
also im 19 jahrhundert und dem frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert oder eigentlich
immer noch aber gerade damals sind als
als religiös anmutende bauten massive
bauten entstanden auch universitäten
meine dieser universität gewissermaßen
die älteren bauten oder vielleicht mehr
als das also auch die teile der tu die
älteren bauten sind wir haben auch diese
wucht des des herrschers oder des
herrscher will man sich also das ist
jetzt nur als fußnote was man sich
vielleicht überlegen könnte die mit ihm
an diesen gedanken dass es das kultur
dokumente auch dokumente der barbarei
sein sollen ohne dass man gleich alles
das kind mit dem bade badewasser
ausschüttet also das ist jetzt alles weg
aber wichtiger ist es zweifellos und das
werden wir noch mehr und uns anschauen
wenn wir zum beispiel bekommen
benjamin hat auch eine andere eigene
thematik vor sich wenn er diese
auseinandersetzung mit der geschichte
führt und zwar mehrfach gewarnt hat eine
theologische auseinandersetzung
ganz wichtig für die einreichung der
geschichte überhaupt also in der
wissenschaft oder oder in der ideologie
ist eine zweiteilung oder eine
gegenüberstellung die schon länger in
der europäischen theologie eine wichtige
rolle spielt nämlich die theorie der
kirche was ist eine kirche was ist die
christliche kirche
ich glaube es gibt ähnliche
auseinandersetzung auch im islam aber
kennedy zu wenig aus die
auseinandersetzung darüber was eine
kirche sein soll war in deutschland
gerade deutschland jahrhundertwende eine
sehr wichtige jahrhundertwende und zwar
ging es um den sogenannten kultur krank
die auseinandersetzung zwischen
protestantischen theologen wie harnack
und katholischen gegnern dass meine dass
das das auch immer noch damals so eine
rolle spielt hat verwundert vielleicht
ein bisschen aber es ist etwas was für
benjamin sehr wichtig ist also den
katholiken eine katholische oder sagen
in anführungsstrichen ich meine jetzt
nicht zwingend für alle katholischen
denke aber schon etwas was ich und
thomas stark anlehnt es gibt eine
katholische vorstellung dessen was eine
kirche ist und es gibt eine literarische
oder aber eine reformatorische vorstelle
und das ist etwas was an den belgier
lesen am geschätzt
[Musik]
von hanno wir uns auch das ist das
faszinierende an diesen ganzen leute
meinen georges mitglied des georg heißt
es war klage ist der unter anderem
liebhaber der reventlow und ja wichtiger
bewohner von schwabing dem benjamin sehr
geschätzt hat und zudem werden wir noch
er einiges zu sagen haben aber er war
auch antisemit sind diese interessanten
schillernd und gedanken gestalten
ebenfalls 2 hahn hat eine wirklich
wichtige theologe und sehr interessant
also seine dogmengeschichte kann ich
ihnen nur empfehlen aber eher einer
1914 unter dem deutschen piloten den
ausbruch des krieges hier begrüßt hat
okay das heute erscheint es uns
vielleicht diese schockierende dabei
natürlich haben dass das viele in ganz
europa gemacht beispielsweise rott
kipling
denn sie sicherlich auch canon autor des
dschungelbuchs war begeistert vom
kriegsausbruch und blieb begeistert bis
sein ältester sohn gefallen ist und das
war natürlich bei etlichen bei vielen
teilnehmern
naja gut also das mache ich nur worum
ging es
die theorie der kirche das übrigens
immer noch eine lebhafte debatte aber
ich denke jetzt wer innerhalb der unter
dem fach theologen nicht
im breiteren rahmen aber jedenfalls also
der gedanke also der der gedanke dem
dabei thomas stark interessiert wird im
mittelalter ist eben dass die kirche
eine symbolische ordnung darstellt die
kirche wirkt durch ihre eigene existenz
sie ist quasi begründet durch christus
der er seine hände auch seine jünger
aufgelegt hat und sie die bischöfe und
priester sind alle r
dieser handauflegung und der priester
weil er es ist ja nur ein mitglied
dieser institution ist hat eine
symbolische kraft und eine symbolische
wirkung
[Musik]
das führt unter anderem beispielsweise
dazu dass eigentlich letztendlich
relativ unwichtig ist wie der wieder
priester
was für ein charakter hat ob es ein
guter oder böser mensch ist oder ob er
gerät ist oder oder überhaupt lesen kann
das alles spielt keine so große rolle
das entscheidende ist ebenfalls was hahn
ag unterstellt und ist beliebtes schon
mit textpassagen aus thomas aber der
gedanke ist also wie gesagt die
persönlichen eigenschaften des
individuellen priesters sind nachrangig
wichtig ist die tatsache dass der
priester durch eine symbolisch durch
einem symbolischen akt zum mitglied der
kirche wird und die kirche ist es also
kirche ist corpus christi
der körper der leib christi in der welt
das ist christophs christus ist hier in
der kirche als kirche und deswegen ist
jeder der durch entsprechende vorgänge
sagen wir mal sakramentale handlungen
aufgenommen wird in diese kirche trägt
eben eine kraft eine wirksamkeit
die unabhängig ist von seinen
unmittelbaren eigenschaften und deswegen
also diese ganze sache wo wir weiter
geschimpft hat beispielsweise das ist
egal es letztendlich nicht
ausschlaggebend was der priester sagt
oder so so lange er im rahmen der kirche
ist eine handlungen aus hört deswegen
auch nach der reformation dann übrigens
auch bei den katholiken aber bis zur
reformation die relative und wichtigkeit
der predigt für die reformatoren war die
predigt ganz richtig aber das ist uns
inzwischen kennen wir das auch in der
katholischen kirche beispielsweise bei
den jesuiten irgendeinem michaelskirche
zum einer hohen kunst geworden ist oder
eigentlich schon immer war bei den
jesuiten das war vor der reformation
nicht eine predigt erfordert einen viel
höheren individuellen persönlichen
einsatz durch die priester was aber im
rahmen des automatischen gedanken gar
nicht so erforderlich
und ob vielleicht auch gar nicht
notwendig ist okay das bedeutet dann
wieder also dass der begriff symbol hier
ist sehr wichtig den werden wir noch
viel intensiver begegnen bank
kammerspiel bucht aber der gedanke des
symbols also symbole
religiöse und im theologischen bereich
sind sichtbar
äußerlich sichtbare handlungen gottes
oder die anwesenheit gottes wird
symbolisch erkennbar in dem sinnlich
erkennbar
deswegen auch die hervorragende
wichtigkeit in der katholischen liturgie
auch von symbolischen handlungen also
dass man sieht und spürt und riecht und
und und was das was abläuft und die
priesterliche tracht sagen wir mal so
die amtstracht ins priester ist ist da
ist ein bestandteil dieser symbolischen
präsenz gottes wie sie wissen ist es
immer noch so priester katholische
priester übrigens auch anglikanische und
nicht nur die katholiken aber im rahmen
dieser kirchen auffassung ist dass der
priester an teilt auch ein wesentlicher
bestandteil seiner wirkung weil das ist
ein symbol wie gesagt symbol ist
sinnlich sinnlich erkennbare präsenz des
heiligen und der priester dessen trägt
er bei der der priester sein
was alles sonst noch weiters ist das
symbolische und egal wie auch wenn der
der priester ebenen drinnen hinter
seinen ganzen farbigen roben eine einen
ganz schlechten charakter das ist für
diese kirchliche und gar nicht so
wichtig weil eben das äußere oder die
lutheraner hätten gesagt dass äußere da
maßgeblich ist okay warum ist das jetzt
wichtig also zum einen wird es wichtig
sein im zusammenhang mit mit dem
trauerspiel bruch aber hier ist es
wichtig weil daraus auch eine
vorstellung geschichte hervorgeht
wenn die institution hier die kirche
der eigentliche träger der identität
oder man könnte jetzt auch sagen kultur
ist dann bögl bildet sich die gerichte
oder alles was in der geschichte eine
rolle spielt in dieser institution und
das ist etwas was sich gerade in der in
der katholischen kirche auch darin
ausdrückt dass die lehre der kirche
teilweise unabhängig ist also natürlich
die heiligen schriften die kirchen fehlt
haben zwar da aber eigentlich wichtig
ist oder geben fast so wichtig ist die
der korpus der lehre die die kirche die
sich selbst entwickelt und das ist ein
langer prozess des dialogs und der
nachforschung der des fragens und und
ist debattieren ist das ganze mit einem
einer lehre
sich entwickelt und diese lehre ist dann
das was jetzt später benjamin als
additiv bezeichnet also die ist schon
immer da und wächst an und hat ein
gewisses da sein
die continuo die kontinuierlich ist es
ist ein kontinuum also eine lehre in
dieser form oder speist sich oder die
kraft dieser lehre speist sich da aus
dem konturen es sind eben keine
unterbrechungen revolutionen weil wenn
es so war es gäbe dann würde das
bisherige entkräftet entwertet und die
kirche ist entrust ein corpus christi
dass sich das bleibt unbeständig ist an
sich entwickelt
das ist ein aspekt dass es nicht das ist
nicht unbedingt schlecht
im gegenteil es gibt eine jetzt aus
nachsichtiger oder sie persönlich das
gut oder schlecht finden
es gibt auch natürlich andere oder viele
institutionen die genauso funktionieren
also ein augenfälligsten ist die
ist das recht vielleicht weniger in
deutschland in deutschland gibt es eine
gewisse spannung zwischen zwei
möglichkeiten aber die die die form in
der das recht sich entwickelt ist auch
ein kontinuum an rechtsprechung und das
in dieser rechtsprechung ist es ein
aktuelles sich fortentwickeln von einer
entscheidung zunächst zur nächsten
das ist etwas sehr deutlich ist in dem
in der angelsächsischen welt so im
sogenannten kommen wo das recht sich von
einer gerichtsentscheidung zur nächsten
entwickelt und dass ich meine deutsch
gesehen würde man sagen ja das ist
richtig toll riecht effektes ist nicht
unbedingt das ist jetzt ein aspekt aber
der punkt ist charakteristisch für
solche institutionen ist dass sie immer
bei sich bleiben also wenn man in
england die an walter heil betrag dann
hat man als grundlage nicht einige so
quasi wissenschaftlich hergestellte
gesetze sondern viel eher eine große
sammlung von vergangenen
gerichtsentscheidungen die zurück
reichen bis ins 16 jahrhundert und von
denen eigentlich alle noch mehr oder
weniger anzuwenden wäre gut also das ist
ein bisschen katholisch meine des kommen
fand seine entwicklung nach der
abtrennung der englischen kirche von von
der katholisch von römisch katholischen
kirche
und da heinrich dem achten aber dieses
system hat das englische recht quasi von
dem von der katholischen kirche
übernommen
gut also wo dabei schlägt ich weiß es
nicht ich meine ich als praktizierender
jurist würde schon sagen wenn ich etwas
wirklich hand ist nachweisen will dann
ist für mich eine gerichtsentscheidung
oder eine höchstgerichtliche
entscheidung das beste ich berufe mich
schon wie alle anderen anwälte in
deutschland auf die höchstgerichtlichen
entscheidung das was als herrschende
meinung bezeichnet wird weil eben das
ist das ist was man als als
ausschlaggebend empfindet ich meine man
kann natürlich auch versuchen uns also
rationaler wäre es so oder so zu machen
aber die gerichte reagieren meistens
wenn das alles ist was wir zu sagen hat
reagieren die gerichte nicht besonders
positiv darauf also man braucht irgendwo
der entscheidung und die entscheidung
ist wie gesagt institution sind herren
genau gehende in der lehre der
katholischen kirche
naja jedenfalls laut harnack und das ist
in deutschland wie gesagt gibt es schon
die spannung zwischen der zwischen
richterrecht und und dem gesetz also es
gibt auch in england aber deutschland
kann man das auch daran erkennen dass es
ist schon möglich für einen deutschen
richter von bild von dem von der
bestehenden rechtsprechung abzuweichen
also wenn er das macht oder wenn sie das
macht
wird seine entscheidung in der wissens
in der nächsten instanz mit einiger
wahrscheinlichkeit dann gekippt aber ist
es zumindest zulässig in england ist es
gar nicht zulässig also das darf der
richter überhaupt nicht insolvenzen
entgegen eine entgegenstehende
entscheidung gibt dann muss sich der
richter daran halten
das ist in deutschland nicht der fall
gut aber jetzt warum ist das wichtig bei
es gibt also die literarische
einstellung und das ist dieser schiene
bewegt sich benjamin die literarische
einstellung ist
wir brauchen diese institution gar nicht
also für thomas ist die institution der
kirche das symbolhafte schlechthin also
das ist gott in der welt für die
lutheraner ist es nicht so der einzelne
christ erlebt gott individuell also der
einzelne christ hatten einen
unmittelbaren zugang zu gott und eine
kirche sozusagen oder eine liturgische
relevante liturgisch relevanter vorgang
ist wenn sie zwei leute zusammen tun mir
braucht es nicht
das ist die leute der lutheranischen
ansatz und rootkits und lehnt den ganzen
den ganzen äußerlichen scheint so zu
sein was er als sein
der katholischen kirche ab also wie sie
wissen heutzutage wenn sie eine
evangelische kirche gehen tagen die
fahrer meistens schwarz also da ist kein
symbol die die tracht es war gut also es
ist schon ein bisschen anders als das
jedenfalls während des gottesdienstes
ist es ist nicht identisch mit dem was
die gemeinde an hat aber meistens aber
diese betonung der tracht oder dass das
symbolisch äußeren existiert bei den
protestanten eben nicht und der gedanke
dann übertragen oder in zusammenhang mit
beispielsweise mit der rechtsprechung
ist eben der gedanke also es gibt die
wissenschaft und die wissenschaft ist
unmittelbar also die wissenschaftler
oder die wissenschaftlerin hat
unmittelbaren zugang zu wahren oder
falschen fakten
es braucht keine institution also die
wissenschaft wäre nach dieser nach
dieser vorstellung dass unmittelbare
beispiel einer ja gut also eine eines
unmittelbaren zugang zur wahrheit
genauso wie der christ nach der
lutheranischen vorstellungen unmittelbar
zugang hat zu gott ja ok aber das ist
dann natürlich auch eine
das schillernde geschichte weil wie sie
wissen oder gerade im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert haben viele philosophen
vorgetragen dass die wissenschaft gar
nicht so naiv unmittelbar ist sondern
gerade auch die naturwissenschaften sehr
institutionell verwobenes impf und das
was die natur wissenschaft entdeckt dann
ist ebenfalls ein produkt der
herrschenden meinung leitet sich ab von
den helfern der herrschenden meinung
auch in dem ich unter den wissenschaft
hat das jetzt nur nebenbei das ist jetzt
nicht so wichtig der punkt hierbei der
theologische gedanke ist dass hier die
vorstellung eines einer kontinuierlichen
geschichte literarisch gesehen
ganz in ganz anderen stellenwert hat
weil die frage ist ja was ist dann das
continuo oder was ist der inhalt der
geschichte nach dieser angeblich
katholischen lehre ist es die
institution und es sind die entwicklung
also stichwort entwicklung oder dann
auch fortschritt innerhalb der in der
institution dass die den inhalt der
geschichte darstellen und der gilt der
geschichtsschreiber muss nur additiv die
diese progression nachzeichnen für den
lutheraner aber gibt es diese geschichte
nicht jedenfalls nicht die geschichte
einer institution für den lutheraner ist
die die geschichtliche diskontinuierlich
oder hat keinen konnten weil das was
zählt ist jemand leute
der unmittelbare zugang zu golfen oder
auch nicht da gibt es nichts worüber man
geschichte schreiben könnte
das einzige worüber wahren geschichte
also der einzige inhalt der geschichte
die wir schon bei kirche dort gesehen
haben sind die herausragenden ereignisse
das spirituell also vor allem natürlich
der tod christi ist dass er eigene ist
worauf sich der protestantische
historiker wir sind das wiedergewinnen
des lebens und des todes von christie
ist der inhalt der geschichte kleinen
protestantischen geschichte
geschichtsschreiber und mehr gibt es
nicht und das ist etwas was wie gesagt
'denk denn die hat stark weg tendiert
von diesem gedanken des des conti nun
ist das übrigens es ist schon auch stark
an bord angelehnt wie sie wahrscheinlich
wissen sich als gegner von hegel
verstanden hat und hier ist ja gerade
der philosoph des containers also hegels
theorie der transformation der
geschichtlichen dialektik ist ein
versuch die veränderung kontinuierlich
zu bilden sozusagen also man hat
konflikt das ist genau das was auch vom
märz übernommen würden wurde
natürlich gibt es konflikte aber jeder
konflikt wird aufgehoben und in eine
neue stufe gefolge fortgeführt und das
ist etwas was was ich mehr oder weniger
deckt mit dem gedanken des
institutionellen kontinuums bei einer
katholischen auffassung dass das
bedeutet dass der ansatz ist oder wenn
man wenn man die geschichte als etwas
kontinuierliches ablehnt dann ist es
nicht ganz so befremdlich wie vielleicht
vorkommen könnte es hängt also die
ablehnung des fortschritte ist hängt
zusammen jedenfalls für benjamin auch
mit diesen dieser theologischen kirchen
theoretischen erwägungen sowie war
benjamin hat hana gelesen
benjamin war sehr gut informiert jüdisch
in gewissen inzwischen aber religiös
oder theologisch waren seine kenntnisse
christlich und vor allem gespeist durch
hat ok also der seien seine vorstellung
der geschichte ist dann quasi eine
radikale protestantische vorstellen
es ist also wie bei kirche gott
zurückblickend und es ist die
früher über dass es in der geschichte
punktuell geschehen ist es die
geschichtsschreibung vorantreibt
ja es ist keine es wird hier nicht die
kultur gefeiert
die kultur als beute der herrschenden
usw ist etwas was ford getragen wird und
in museen aufbewahrt und wunder also
dass wird abgelehnt in dem sinne dass
jetzt die geschichte verstanden werden
soll
als einbruch von katastrophen die
gerecht werden müssen jetzt nicht schon
nach
das ist jetzt der hintergrund der punkt
ist dass benny jetzt theorie der
geschichte wie gesagt nicht so abstrus
ist wie man vielleicht denken könnte und
wenn er sagt die geschichte soll die
geknechteten vorfahren erreichen
denn dieses parallel etwas politisch
abgemildert oder umfunktioniert es ist
nur der protestantische gedanke der also
der protestantische gedanke ist der
unmittelbare zugriff auf die tragödie
der vergangenheit ich meine christus ist
ja gestorben das ist eine tragödie
also nicht nur das sondern wir auch
gehört sagt sie
war eine herausforderung er einen
konflikt zu seinem zeitalter hatte
gerade mit den jüdischen priestern und
weiter nichts zu tun oder oder hat sie
nur provoziert es waren lauter negative
sachen aber gerade darin dass sich das
negativ erinnert bricht man aus bricht
man heraus aus diesen bedrückenden
konditoren was ansonsten in den
institutionen der kirche vielleicht aber
auch der wissenschaft und den
kulturinstitutionen die von der kreis so
angehimmelt wurden
man bricht daraus hervor und ist dann
also wie er sagt als sprung unter dem
freien himmel der geschichte erledigt
sich dieser ganzen lasten und wie kommen
zu einem klaren verständnis von
irgendwas an allein durch individuell
einsicht ja also das ist ja gedanken
das ist quasi der etwas versteckt das
versteck thema dürfen jetzt etwas was
jetzt noch wichtig wäre aber das werde
ich nur kurz umreißen ist die frage wie
soll das gehen
wir haben mit zwei fahren also die eine
frage ist ja woran sollen wir uns jetzt
erinnern
das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so einfach
meine für theologisch ist relativ
einfach ja okay mir kriegst du hast gut
aber
benjamin geht es geht es nicht unbedingt
um christus die beispiele die das hatten
wir schon gesehen also ob er oder die
französische revolution erinnert sich an
ein büro oder vor allem an die römische
republik und verfall und so weiter das
ist etwas woran woran die die franzosen
sich innert haben in diesen retten den
augenblicken der einsicht was ist jetzt
für uns heute das lässt er bisschen
offen und ich denke jeder musst du bist
eigenen beispielen finden also ein
gewissermaßen aber schon sehr stark ins
institutionalisiertes beispiel ist
natürlich die show von benjamin damals
noch nicht wusste ob das jetzt passen
würde zu benjamins gedanken dass man die
geknechteten vorfahren rächen sollte ich
weiß aber ist ebenfalls eine möglichkeit
ist als focus irgendwie das
geschichtsbewusstsein ist der durchaus
darstellbar
vielleicht weiß das nicht aber wie
gesagt beispiel muss man sich selber
auch so
der zweite punkt ist was ich letzte
woche schon angesprochen hat
die die frage der methode weil benjamin
hat sehr konkrete vorstellungen wie man
methodisch hier vorgeht und zwar es sind
es ist das was er essen oder oder sein
begriff dafür wie man die geschichte
konstruieren sollte ist das dialektische
bild das dialektische bild er sagt so
ist ja in fünf in der 5
das wahre bild über das ist ein grund
warum die shoah vielleicht schwer hier
einzuordnen ist aber das wahre bild der
vergangenheit huscht vorbei nur als bild
das es nimmer wiedersehen im augenblick
seines erkämpfter erkennbarkeit eben
aufblitzt ist die vergangenheit
festzuhalten also das ist jetzt diese
methode
was ist es was ich als als historiker
wahrnehmen festhalte aufschreibe und da
sagt er es sind bilder und es sind
bilder die aufblitzen
auf nimmerwiedersehen im augenblick
seiner erkennbarkeit
das sind lauter für benjamin lauth
begriffe die theoretisch besetzt sind
und das werden wir ein anderes mal etwas
ausführlicher besprechung ein bisschen
aber jetzt ganz kurz bild der begriff
bild ist ein band lang anklage
erkenntnistheorie klages in seinem
beispielsweise in seiner schrift von
cosmo konischen heraus das klingt auch
etwas seltsam aber es ist schon ein
interessantes und sehr gut geschriebenes
werk also wenn sie mal zweiten
reinzuschauen wirklich klar ist klages
theorie der bilder ist quasi eine eine
re interpretation von platon also bei
platon sind idee hat uns auch die
grundlage von erkennen und gedenken und
wahrheit sind die idee ideen sind quasi
destinationen begriffliche destinationen
der möglichkeit also wir erkennen ich
erkenne weil die ideen die ich in meinem
kopf habe übereinstimmen mit den
strukturen der wirklichkeit und das
herausragende beispiel dafür ist
natürlich die mathematik also die
mathematik ist wenn ich sage ein apfel
mit einem 28 28
das ist sowohl begrüße ich als auch ja
also das ist quasi die fundamentale
eigenschaft einer idee für platte
übereinstimmung von von begriffen und
wirklichkeit und und gerade
wie mathematik oder die arithmetik
jedenfalls er weiß ich als letzt letzten
nachweis dieser übereinstimmung weil
diese ganzen komplexen gebilde die ich
mit der arithmetik oder noch mehr
vielleicht mit der weiteren mathematik
aber ebenfalls in der arithmetik schon
diese komplexen fordern die ich
entwickeln kann decken sich eins zu eins
mit der außenwelt ja das ist das
argument dass platonische argument und
beispielsweise dann auch die
himmelskörper die eine regelmäßig eine
berechenbare regelmäßigkeit aufweisen
auch dort ist das ein nachweis dafür
also ich meine die unmittelbar vor
kindliche welt ist chaotisch und dreckig
und uns unheimlich aber beispielsweise
bei den himmelskörpern ist es ist es
eine reine bewegung rein mathematische
bewegung und das sind ideen gut also
dass wird von von klage ist umgekehrt
bei ihnen sind es nicht die idee sind
keine ideen sondern bilde dir die
eigenschaft von bildern es eben geht
die die sinnlichkeit also nicht das
abstract begriffliche sondern sind es
erscheinen und sinnlicher erscheinungen
so visuelle erscheinungen oder brüche
oder oder töne oder was auch immer gut
das ist dass das ist das also das ist
ein radikaler empirismus also bei platon
die wahrheit im abstrakten steckt also
in dem was berechenbar ist und geistig
ist bei klage es umgekehrt
das ist schon viel von nietzsche dabei
aber es werden sie sicherlich erkennen
aber der punkt ist ein bild ist gerade
keine idee ein bild in dem sinne dass
ein bild ist etwas was ich sinnlich
erfahren und auch wenn es über 1
einmalig ist
also ich schaue aus dem fenster und
jetzt gerade liegt noch kein schnee die
bäume sind nackt gerade wohl wo die
blätter hängen und wo nicht das ist
einmalig es wird nie wiederkehren
also wenn ich morgen rausguckt und
lauten andere menschen rum und epe und
so dieses bild ist einmalig weshalb wir
plattform ist das ein entscheidend dafür
dass die bilder letztendlich nicht sehr
interessant sind weil das verändert sich
die ganze zeit aber gerade darin der
einmaligkeit der bilder ist für klages
deren stärke als objekt ist eine
einmalige erscheinung besinnlicher
erscheinung
das ist natürlich auch ich meine miete
man denkt angeblich seine theorien ist
eine musiktheorie dass seine schriften
über wagner hängt auch damit zusammen
also die musik ist nicht das
begriffliche ist sondern es sind töne
sind ton bild da die einmalig und sind
uns nicht verflüchtigen natürlich kann
man die die vorstellung wiederholen aber
dann ist das ist einfach
andere vorstellungen jeden abend also
jedes mal dass das was aufgeführt wird
es ist anders aber jedes mal ist ein
vollwertiges bild also das ist es eine
mit dazu werden wir noch mehr zu sagen
haben wer arbeitet bild ist der erste
begriff der sehr wichtig ist in diesem
satz und 5
der wahre bild das wahre bild der
vergangenheit fast vorbei ist vorbei und
das ist das einzig wahre
also wenn ich versuche das bild passe zu
analysieren und begrifflich auseinander
zu drosseln
dann habe ich es verloren dann ist es
nur sowas geistig ist aber kein bild
mehr keine realität und der zweite punkt
das damit zusammenhängt in diesen in
dieser erkenntnistheoretischen
geschichte ist der begriff augenblick zu
augenblick aus den gründen die ich
gerade erklärt habe dh es ist
charakteristisch für bilder dass sie nur
in augenblicken erscheinen
im gegensatz zur hermann enz was
bezeichnen ist für begriffe also
begriffe ist in ewig 2+2 gleich vier ist
eine ewige wahrheit und es liegt meine
das ist der grund warum diese wahrheit
so wichtig wäre
fatalistisch müsse ihn aber für klage es
ist es umgekehrt
weil die wahrheit ewig ist gerade
deswegen bringt sie uns nicht wählen
diese begrifflichkeit ok und augenblick
ist auch etwas als beim kindergarten
eine wichtige rolle spielt es ist eine
übersetzung oder die deutsche
entsprechung des kritischen ace das ist
auch in der in der klassischen
philosophie was wichtig ist und wie
gesagt hier ist
lasst uns einfach dabei dass das hier
bild und augenblick wichtige komponenten
sind oder die wichtigen die
fundamentalen komponenten für benjamin
erkenntnistheorie im zusammenhang mit
der geschichte aber das möchte ich für
nächste woche auf sparen so das war was
ich sagen wollte als sie